[Musique]
c'était un pari audacieux un défi risqué
faire entrer l'art contemporain dans ce
château marquée par la présence
lumineuse de catherine de médicis
et diane de poitiers par quel biais
trouver un dénominateur commun
comment écrire une nouvelle page de
cette histoire et faire rimer le passé
le présent la tradition et de la
modernité
c'était un vrai défi d'installer l'art
contemporain dans un lieu patrimonial un
lieu qui était connue pour son festival
des jardins
un défi que je pense aujourd'hui on peut
dire que nous avons relevé avec plus de
75 commandes artistiques qui ont été
réalisés dans le château dans les
communs dans les parcs avec une centaine
d'expositions en tout en disant l'art
contemporain a trouvé sa place au
château de chaumont-sur-loire partout où
le regard se pose c'est un jaillissement
un émerveillement une composition un
dialogue permanent l'art contemporain
désormais nous est devenu familier
mieux ils nous tuent toi
[Musique]
on travaille essentiellement sur la
thématique de la nature avec des
artistes qui utilisent le bois la brume
l'eau tous les éléments de la nature et
le regard qu'il porte sur la nature est
un regard qui interroge notre vision du
monde notre vision de la nature c'est un
regard à la fois écologique et poétique
et artistique et je crois qu'après
toutes ces années on peut se dire que
ils nous aident à mieux voir notre monde
magnifie la beauté de ce monde c'est une
sorte de sublimation mais qui déclenche
aussi des interrogations parce que on
sait très bien que cette nature est
menacée de partout chaumont est un lieu
de partage de la rue doublé d'un
quotidien difficile et nous élargit
l'horizon et nous plonge dans une sorte
de rêve
on a besoin de ce rêve et je pense que
les artistes sont en mesure de nous
apporter cette dimension onirique à
chaumont-sur-loire l'art contemporain a
cessé d'être hermétique élitiste abscons
les dix dernières années ont été un bain
de jouvence
une découverte une initiation puis il
évident
les artistes ont chaque fois su
bousculer nos certitudes nous poussés
dans nos retranchements
nous émouvoir aussi